ん
[音楽]
ええええええ
上智大学で入学を果たし指は一つかない花キャンパスライフを夢見て上京してきた18
歳山本ない日
今何だか丁寧に説明
18年会が誰しもしてきて一さんの貢献
いわゆる建設破壊神学校に勝っていたのでも前僕は5号から幼稚ですべて正確お話し
ます
真面目に勉強したい課外活動力取り組んでみたい
深夜歌舞伎町でハメを外してみた今します
話で行って名前にストをちょっとした成功体験で
鼻栓雲テーブル
メインを見まくっていますん
周りから見たらこれでめちゃめちゃ面白人間なんてね
まずせそうなってるでしょみたいな
その自尊心に溢れ返っていました
そんなに大学2年生19歳から20歳になった頃の話ですけど僕はあることに気付いて
しまったです
俺ってこの後どうなるん
基とされに全く答えられない自分がああいうことに気づいてしまったんです
の人生を送りだのかそこに近づくためにはどうしたらよ
こんな壮大なとっだけどここにいる皆さんの関係なんという
こんなこれに関する話を今日この場をありでお話しさせていただきます
突然ですが54%
漢数字だと思いますか
これは2018年の新成人に関する意識調査において
将来にははあるかという質問を繰り返している女があると答えた新成人の方です
これちなみに2008年から調査を合わせて過去最低です
今夢はあるかと聞かれてあなたは夢があると胸を張った応えることができますか
今夢があると心の中で答え出し詰まるほど人に質問です
その夢はどこまで具体的ですか
状態にあったらかなと言いますか
いつかないですかどうやっていかないんですか
そのためには何ができますか
今日から何を始めるんですか
誰の力はれなければいけませんか
そして僕の基準ではこれらにある程度応えられる状態じゃなければ夢とは言い難いと
考えています
なぜならば夢はある程度具体的じゃないと
そのときの気分でコロコロ変わってしまうのだと考えているからです
例えば幼稚園児は将来の夢は世界一のファッション選手ですと宣言してしばらく経って
から商談に入るは思わりさんですと言うようなものです
これが終わるとありませんがこれを見てくださっている方々きっとそんな悠長なこと
言ってる場合ではないですね
そしてお店になっていく僕たちがそれで少々心もとないのではないかなと思ってしまい
ます
それはを鑑みればこのデータは半数以上が夢があると答えていますがそれらを監視でき
なくなってくるんじゃないですか
また次のデータを見てもらうとなかなか厳しい状況に置かれていることがわかると思い
ます
こちらは日本財団の
調査ですん
ご覧の通りや草の先進国と比べて日本はすべての水準でを科学人を下回っています
黒の責任があるかなと思いますん
送りに解決したしたいから
自分の力で社会を変えられるとも思えません
将来年
残念ですがこれが今の日本の若者現状です
そして様僕も目標もなくりしていた若者の一人です
に行動してみたりしていなかっん
もちろん目標なんかなくても行動してみたり人に会ったりして楽しかったですし
dj に何らかも知れ個ありました
学びもたくさんいましたん
そういうことに共感できる人も多いはずです
でも後悔したことがあります
それは何を言っても結果が出ないことです
先ほども話しましたが目標のないそれらの行動は基本的に長続きしないです
これまでの人生何かに打ち込んだ授業を目指してください
例えばたきゃんべんきょ
憧れの大学でのキャンパスライフ学歴専攻分野のために寝る版も支持ドライブできまし
た
例えば部活動チーム一丸となって甲子園出場や県大会ベスト4な共通の目標に向かって
全力を尽くし
涙出すことができました
に共通するもう
目標があったぞ
だからこそ圧倒的な努力を継続することができ
そしてさんは西談集にゃんも協力をしてくれた
そして結果を待つことができた
の実はどうでしょう
次戦の目標はありますでしょ
継続的に圧倒的な努力をすることができるでしょ
周囲の人間はあなたの人生に協力してくれるでしょ
プールのな人生
それを結果が仕組まれてるんですよ
いうような言葉があります
為せば成る為さねば成らぬ何事
長沼人の為さなりきっ
あなたができないん
人ができないのやらないから
とてもシンプルですね
とはいえ目標なんてそんな彼も見つからないですよ
までも焦らなくて大丈夫ですそのためのラトリア
大学生活ですかっ
そこで何から手をつけているかわからないというあなたにこれだけは多いで教えている
ことを何点か提案させて頂ければと思います
あればもっと通り将来から逆算していくことが成功なんですがとりあえず彫金の課題に
ついて特に大学生
何のために首相するとかなのために執着しながら就職した後はどうなりたいのか
ん
それは具体的に言うとアンダーの宿を定めています
それが定まれば直近ぶち当たり村対策やの写真を使うことがあります
あとは目標がないなら9票見つけることも杏仁してみましょう
ん
そして目標を見つければ目標にしてるなんやどうすればいいかというものを考えて自分
なりに模索しながら足を動かしています
止まらずに動き続けてみましょう生まれながら考えて答えが出ないまま変わらないん
ですけど
変わらない景色を見つめていても答えが出てこないのと同じです
見たこともないで式に向かっていっ
時には動きもあることも大切です
今の自分と目標を見つけていき一成
それがどれだけかなっているん
いただければ何も様々に辿り着く所が出ちゃうのか
藤井釣太郎
実行してみません
そうそういうことで皆様の人生が今までよりももっと皆さん
思ったとおりに近い方向に進んでいくだけです
私は先輩起業家に相談なんでもあったり時には見切り発車してみることで自分に自問
自答を繰り返し自分にとってのマナーのかを考えました
そのようにして自分はすべての人間の術たらやりてぇを実現するという目標を持ちその
目標もとに行動を起こすようになります
岩ブレザーを行っているこの車間朝に目標を持ち行動していくことの一例です
すべての人間の全てのを焼いたら出現するという一つの目的からチェック参加を決意し
た
さんに対して自分の際でお伝えたいん
そして賛同してくださったみなさん一緒に僕
透明度社会を実現したいと思い今日この場になっています
以上に自分自身のラインなりましたがあなたがあなたらしい必要
あなたので切るためにも
あなたが目標を立ててそのためにあなたが医療行ってみましょう
よくなんか持たずに今を謳歌するのもいいですが目標を持っていっ
目標を持ってもあなた次第でもっと人生を多くする豪華することができるはずです
じゃない日曜日の目標のない人生は味気なく
あっけなく終わってしまうのです
私でこの人生何してたんだっけで
思いながら市の櫛田たないように今の焦るほど
何かを増すためになるまでなしてみましょう
最後にもう一度聞きます
何にでもなれるこの人生で本来の中でこんな取材 day
あなたが本当に心の底から送りたいと
思いを年生は
一体どんな人生でしょ